[Music]
many communities across the country are
concerned about lead in water supplies
but in Philadelphia some parents are
worried about what's in the ground
they're convinced high levels of lead
and soil put their children at risk for
irreversible brain damage the
Philadelphia Inquirer and Daily News
recently tested more than 100 parks
playgrounds and backyards in the cities
were rewards nearly 75 percent of the
area's tested had hazardous levels of
lead Jericka Duncan spoke with one
family demanding solutions dareka good
morning good morning construction
projects in what's known as the river
Ward section are on the rise now some
parents worry that when construction
crews don't follow dust regulations
hazardous lead particles could end up in
places where children play she gets
frustrated really easily and you know
that could be every three-year-old or it
could be as a result of that elevated
lead you just want know there's not a
day that goes by that Jana Curtis and
her husband bill pace don't look at
their three-year-old daughter Nolan and
wonder whether she'll have lifelong
damage from lead in 2015 her parents
found out she had a blood lead level of
14 that's almost three times the level
the CDC says is cause for concern what
was your initial reaction when you heard
that heartbroken really you know you do
so much to protect your kids and then to
realize that that you failed in that is
is terrifying
exposure to abnormally high levels of
lead can cause developmental delays at
one and a half Nolan spoke only two
words her parents quickly enrolled her
in speech therapy as you did the
research and you found out more what
this means for your daughter
I actually got more scared the more I
read about it the family found out their
backyard soil had elevated levels of
lead
only after the Environmental Protection
Agency went door to door to test homes
for lead including its soil for the past
several years the EPA has been doing
that type of testing in this
neighborhood because the area was once
home to at least 14 chemical plants that
release lead waste our soil sample came
back at over 11
hundred over 1,100 yeah which is close
to three times the limit for play spaces
for kids recent town hall meetings have
been packed with parents of small
children who are concerned about the
various ways lead can spread reporter
Wendy Ruderman worked on the
Philadelphia Inquirer Daily News
investigation she says unregulated
construction sites may be contributing
to the problem we found lots of sites
with just giant heaping piles of dirt
left uncovered blowing in the wind even
if people have low levels of lead dr.
Thomas Farley is Philadelphia's health
commissioner the most important thing is
to be wetting the material so the dust
isn't generated when they demolish the
houses have the contractors been doing
that we know that the contractors are
not following those recommendations now
or those requirements now after the
interview a spokeswoman for the city
said Parks and Rec facilities near a
construction site will now be hosed down
several times a week signs will be
posted at all Parks and Rec facility
sites reminding kids to wash their hands
and contractors have been sent letters
reminding them of the city's air
management quality laws but dr. Farley
says lead levels and children outside of
the river wards area are even higher we
think that the primary source of
exposure for lead in children today is
the interior paint nationwide the CDC
reports that lead paint may account for
up to 70% of the elevated lead levels
there may very well be some contribution
from soil but that doesn't appear to be
the major source but any source says
father of three bill pace is worthy of
the city's attention if you really want
to eradicate lead poisoning in the kids
in the city you have to take away a
hundred percent not seventy and to
ignore the 30% I think is a huge mistake
no one's parents replace the topsoil and
now mop twice a day to avoid further
exposure Nolan's blood level is now at a
four and she's taking iron supplements
her parents say she is doing better but
they're still worried bottom line there
are unsafe levels of soil in many urban
neighborhoods across the country doctors
say knowing about the
and testing your children early are the
best ways to prevent lead poisoning
Thanks a lot of good information here
Thank You jurika